hi guys oh my gosh season four how does
that feel I don't believe it's you
already I know it's crazy
um yeah I was just saying it to someone
else earlier today and it's like when
you think that five years ago we started
and you've no idea I don't know if
you're gonna have a job and again in two
months or whatever it's so crazy to be
here five years later the season
definitely felt actually I remember
you've it felt like it went the fastest
yeah it really sort of flew in and um
yeah I can't believe we're here and
we've actually got another two to go
yeah how is your relationship changed in
the last four seasons of working
together it's it's almost as bad as
every day this is the only time you
actually see us together
I see at me I've told you you're not
allowed to look at me the CG ayah says
both in the scenes her doubles greater
oh yeah I prefer his double it looks you
can't tell guys so what sort of how is
Jamie and Clare's relationship changed
now that they're in America you know
it's really nice this season because I
think we get to play this this mature
relationship that has really settled and
is really content you know I think prior
seasons there was always this will they
won't they element to their dynamic and
I think we've we've stepped away from
any cliffhangers now and they're like
solid and it's nice to see that inner
mechanisms of a relationship being able
to work through problems yeah and
they're there now a strong unit together
and it means that you know that they're
in this land and they're building this
new life for themselves and laying the
foundations for a new America and also
having an influence on on you know their
children or their child Brianna in the
future so how like has it been shifting
that from obviously it's been in
Scotland in Paris and now it is in
America I mean I've seen a lot of bald
eagles yeah
somebody somebody went with a camera to
America and film some bullets of a lot
of bald eagles yeah
um you know it was really interesting I
think prior to this season we've always
were usually shooting in Scotland for
Scotland and Scotland has so many
incredible stately homes and historic
castles no fire engines but obviously
colonial America looks very different to
mean North Carolina and Scotland do
share a lot of similarities in the
topography and the landscape but we had
to do a lot of building of sats from
ground up and John Geary steel did just
the most incredible job this season
whether it's building a frontier town
like Wilmington or the plantation at
Riverrun
it just all it was incredible it was
incredible for us a little strange
actually because everything is new in
northern Islander you know we're filming
very old locations and it's all broken
down and they're throwing dust and mud
and things on it and then suddenly we're
in these very clean you like I'm you're
gonna break that down a bit and I no no
because it's just been built and of
course that's America it's this sort of
new new land
um so last time if to Canada spoke with
you you told us that you had nicknames
for Sam and it was just mid Matt Brown
Dusty Rhodes just yeah they are they
come out now and then mmm yeah I'm sure
you do know we don't actually know well
there's some kind of Maggie Claire
[Laughter]
really no we don't I think we will
create some we'll work on that in season
five building real oh yeah well hey Jim
next time
so what are you most excited for for
fans to see this season there's a
particular scene or moment well I think
one of my favorite moments or scenes we
actually filmed at the very end
we are with some of our mohawk friends
and it was there was some canoeing hmm
may have been it's gonna I definitely
say that I feel like this end of season
and this finale which I know is jumping
too far ahead but the finale is probably
one of the strongest we've done it felt
like a lawyer's is very it's very
exciting and I think we had the most fun
filming that as well it's it's very kind
of action-packed but visually I think
it's gonna be really stunning and I
think we all just really enjoyed it and
there's a lot of Canadians in it there's
a lot of Canadians yeah in America in
America - all right well thank you so
much guys really appreciate it thank you
thanks